So today we're going to talk about graph
neural Nets and some Library called
pytor's geometric for processing such
kind of neural networks so this talk
will be a very introductory some Basics
regarding graph neural nets for those of
you who've never worked with them
the agenda would be a very quick
introduction to geometric deep learning
which is a special type of deep learning
algorithms or area of research of deep
neural Nets related to processing some
specific types of data which we will
talk about next
some specific architectures like graph
neural Nets
the key idea behind graph neural Nets
which is called message passing we will
talk about it it more
and introduction to the one of the
libraries for processing of such
architectures pytors geometric it's not
not the only Library there are other
libraries for processing graph neural
Nets but we will use Python geometric
for just demonstration purposes and we
will see how to write a very simple
graph neural net in Python geometric
uh yep
start recording now we're recording okay
so this is our agenda again quick
introduction to geometric deep learning
graph neural Nets and message passing
and a low World application using
pytor's geometric it's a very simple
graph neural map
okay let's start from the basics let's
recall what is deep learning of course
it's a multi-head beast with a lot of
different applications and different
type of types of neural Nets but
in most of the cases we can consider
deep learning as a way of constructing
algorithms which we call models which
transform data from some input to some
output basically a mapping from X to Y
this these models
has some parameters
and these parameters are adjusted during
the training procedure and usually we
train these models with supervised
learning meaning we have correct answers
for our input so for this input I want
this output and we then run our models
at inference stage and these models
producing the correct results because
they are trained to do so but the
question here is what kind of model can
we use and what kind of data can we use
as input as output so let's consider
different cases
so the simplest case we have just simple
data some vectors some long-dimensional
information pieces and for that we can
use some classical machine learning
approaches or multi-layer perceptrons or
you can call them fully connected neural
Nets very simple right but what if you
have something more complicated like
images or videos so which type of neural
Nets do we use for images who knows
right convolutional neural Nets images
videos audios something where we have a
signal and we have local features when
we have when we want to extract some
local information around some points
for text audio and sequences for audio
you can see that we have both recurrent
neural Nets and cnns we can have
different combinations of these Networks
or neural Nets and recently we have
Transformers for
natural language processing for
translation Etc
but for graphs what do we have for
graphs okay so we can try to apply for
example multi-layer perceptron or fully
connected networkers but what's the
problem for example for applying FC
fully connected networks to graphs well
first obvious problem is that graphs can
have multiple different variations and
it can have variable length so we can
have graph with 10 nodes or 20 nodes
it's not obvious how to pass them into
this multi-layer perception with fixed
input length we can try to apply
recurrent neural network but through
current neural network suppose that you
have some order but in graph graph is
unordered structure mostly so you don't
have a specific order how you pass your
graph right
uh convolution neural Nets a bit closer
because for convolutional neural Nets
it's important what's the what are the
features in the local region of your
image or a video in graphs you can also
think of hey I have these neighbors
around my node and I want to use these
informations to somehow aggregate this
information and to calculate something
within a node but you cannot apply cnns
like straightforward to graphs because
cnns are for
matrices for tensors for something which
we could also call euclidean data
structures but graphs are non-euclidean
data structures there are no vectors no
uh matrices no tensors so it's a bit
more complicated structure what are the
examples of
graphs and what kind of tasks can we
have with graphs well you can name a few
yourself but some obvious examples
molecules some
biological science in biological science
you have for example conic terms things
which are which has some notes and some
connections you can think of drug
Discovery how can we find a new type of
molecule for treating some diseases Etc
so everything related to biology and
chemistry also you can think of social
graphs for example node could be a node
could be a human or a person and a
connection would be a friendship
relations or something else or you can
think of
set of different documents and links
between those documents and so on and
Third Kind of set of tasks is processing
of 3D data 3D models meshes Etc that's
not the ultimate list you can think of
any other types of tasks where you also
can have graphs
a bit more
terminal a bitter knowledge about graphs
so a graph is a set of nodes and a set
of edges between those nodes and age can
have a direction or it can be
undirectionfly or you can think of
bidirectional so it can point from Node
1 to node 3 and backwards from node 3 to
node 1. if we are not drawing any arrows
that means that it's a undirected graph
if there are some arrows that means it's
a directed graph
we can think of a nodes as a set of
things here it is represented as a
vector of some entities but important
thing is that in graphs the order is not
important so every operation which we
perform on graphs should be invariant in
terms of some permutations so there is
no strict order like one two three four
five we can order these nodes in any
order but we must preserve ordering
between nodes and corresponding edges so
we need to
take consider this information when we
process graphs
okay so for nodes we simply can stack
them in into a vector in some order but
what about ages how do we store
information about edges there are
multiple ways of storing information
regarding edges but one way is to store
ages in adjacency Matrix it's a square
Matrix for simple graphs the dimensions
of this of this Matrix is a number of
nodes per number of nodes it's Square
Matrix and in each element of this
Matrix you have either 0 or 1 and 1
means there is a connection between node
J and node I if it's a undirected graph
then this Matrix will be symmetric
because you have a connection from J to
I and from I to J that's why it is a
symmetric Matrix in this example
another example of a graph
it is directed graph you have arrows
here and this means that for example in
adjacent to matrix it's not symmetric
anymore
we have some ones and some zeros and
for example connection from Node 1 to
node 3 is represented as one in this
Matrix
with
Row 1 and column three so again from
Node 1 to node 3 Row 1 colon 3 that's
the one in The adjacency Matrix
and there are other ways of representing
adjacency matrices or edges in our graph
for example this graph connectivity can
be also expressed in this compact form
also called coo format or coordinate
format the dimension of this Matrix is 2
by number of edges
and each column just represents the pair
of corresponding nodes for example we
have again this connection from one to
three and we have this one three pair
and the order is not important in this
Matrix right because there is no
specific ordering of these edges so
these are the basis of graphs and this
will be used in future for in our future
demonstration
now let's talk about graph neural Nets
so we want to process graphs somehow
that means that we need some model some
deep learning model where as input we
pass our graph and it outputs something
there are different
possibilities what can we output as
output it could be another graph or it
could be some vector or a value for
example we want to do classification
over graphs that means our output will
be just a label or a vector of
distribution over classes or you can do
regression that means the output would
be some tensor or vector
another case we want some graph as
output in simplest case we want the same
graph but for each node we want to
transform the data somehow these are
kind of different possibilities but
first what we need to do we have I like
our row graph but we need to assign some
information some data to its entities
for example the simplest case we want to
assign some Vector feature Vector to
each node
in a more complicated scenario you can
also have feature representation for
edges right but in simplest case you
have just nodes
for each node you have some feature
Vector it could be actually not a vector
it could be any type of data you will
not just need to have a way to process
the data for example it could be an
image or a text anything you just want
to have some local transformation
function for this type of data and then
you can apply like graph notation on top
of that so let's for simplistically
consider just raw so sorry yeah row
feature vectors for each node and we
have some edges edges could be
represented as a adjacency matrix or as
a COO connectivity Matrix
now how do we process graphs
our first step would be to take the
graph and produce another graph and here
are some again some possibilities in the
simplest case
within this transformation we want to
obtain the same graph in terms of the
topology but each node will have
different feature vectors so basically
we're transforming feature vectors
within that graph but taking into
account the connectivity of different
nodes between each other and then we
repeat this procedure and you can think
of these arrows as layers like in
general in simple neural Nets you have
layer one layer 2 Etc and for example in
pi torch geometric when you construct
graph neural Nets such Transformations
also usually treat it as different
layers
so in simplest scenarios the graph will
remain its topology and structure but
the features will be changed somehow
or in more complicated cases we can have
also transformed graphs somehow at the
output of such layer for example there
are some pooling operations where as
output we get a reduced graph or
unpulling operations when we get larger
graphs but in simplest case the graph
remains
and another opportunity we can have a
global pooling where as input we have
graph and as output we have something
single like a single Vector single value
or single tensor but with no graph as
out
but let's consider first the simplest
types of operations when we have graph
as input graph as output
what's the basic idea of processing
graphs well of course we can just apply
some transformation for each node right
but in this case we will not have any
aggregation of information from
Neighbors from other points
let's consider some aggregation of
information the simplest way of
aggregate information is to consider
neighbor
nodes of current node for example we
want to compute new value for the node
which is orange here and we want to use
its neighbors
and the mechanism behind this is called
message passing so it's a key idea in
graph neural Nets it's just called
message passing and the idea is that we
basically pass some message from
Neighbors to this node and aggregate the
result and update the feature Vector of
this node
in more details
let's consider our Target node x i and
some neighboring node x j and there is
an h e j i and usually I means Target
node and J means some neighboring node
or the source of information
we can define a function which takes x i
x j and the h
and this function is basically the
message from XJ to x i it could be any
function and important thing is it is a
trainable function it's a learnable
function so when we will construct the
graph neural net out of it we will train
it end to end and the parameters of this
function hidden parameters of this
function will be updated during the
training now we have right now the
function which gets which passes the
message from one node to another node
but we also have some set of neighbors
for this particular node and we need
some function to aggregate this
information so this
a unique unification sign just means
some way of aggregating this information
an important property of this
aggregation information aggregation
function should be uh
invariance in terms of a permutation of
the neighbors so we can pass Neighbors
in any order and aggregation functions
should return the same result the
simplest examples could be like
averaging or taking maximum volume
Etc like in pooling operations and
finally when we calculated aggregated
message from all the neighbors we
calculate some update
we've taken we we take all the
information coming from neighboring
nodes we take our current feature vector
and pass it to another function which is
also could be also trainable and we
update the value of x i
and that's the simplest and more as
general as possible representation of a
graph neural net layer this mechanism
again is called message passing and the
then we can start modifying these things
and start to for example selecting
different functions for Phi for gamma
and for this U operator and depending on
which particular representation of this
function we choose we get different
types of layers of graph neural Nets and
there are dozens of papers available and
different papers use different functions
and you have different
in certain implementations of the graph
neural net layers
one example example let's say we have
a set of neighboring nodes XJ for each
feature Vector we apply simple linear
transformation meaning that we multiply
them by matrix W that will give us some
another representation of each
neighboring node W multiplied by x j
then as aggregation we will take some
simple summation and you will see that
you see that under this sum we have J's
those indexes J which are neighbors of
node I
and after the summation we just pass it
to some activation function like real or
sigmoid and that's it and then we just
assign it to X
and let's take one step back the
important note is that
we will we will do this operation for
each node but in parallel so each node
will run this operation synchronously so
it's not like we calculated this
operation for one node then we move to
the next node and use this updated
information no we calculate everything
in parallel in synchronous mode
synchronous mode right
this is the simplest example and you can
see some
relation to a convolutional operator
here so what's a convolution right we
have our pixel into the images we have
some neighbors we we multiply these
neighbors by some weights we aggregate
them together and this is a result for
this location and we perform this for
multiple locations so this is very
similar here in graphs we have neighbors
multiplying them by some weights
aggregate them together and do this for
every location that's why these type of
types of graph neural Nets or types of
graph neural net layers sometimes called
convolutional graph neural Nets with
some modifications actually
and as I said there are different
variations of this functions so message
passing protocol is a general
representation but we can have different
types of messages for example what I
showed you previously it's kind of
called convolutional graph neural net
but in some particular papers there are
actually a bit different formula a bit
more complicated but the idea is similar
we can have a bit more complicated ways
to pass message for example using
attention mechanism what's attention
mechanism in for example in recurrent oh
sorry in NLP it means that when we
aggregate results from different nodes
or from different words in NLP we
calculate different coefficients for
different parts and here we also can
calculate different importance
coefficients for different nodes
using the same attention mechanism you
can for example pass a feature Vector of
your node
and future Vector of your target node to
some neural net which will produce the
coefficient the importance coefficient
of this particular neighbor node
and then you can pass it to softmax and
just get a coefficients and then you
when you aggregate you not treat all of
them equally but you multiply them by
some coefficients that's an attention
mechanism and there are different
variations there's there are a lot of
different papers this is a very rapidly
changing field and basically people are
trying to invent some new ways of
passing messages or different ways of
calculating aggregation in the simplest
cases are calculating average or mean or
using maximum value or something else
also for the update you can think of
something more complicated
for example you can multiply just the
result vector by some Matrix and then
pass it to this node this will be linear
or you can think of a more complicated
thing like RNN what does it mean well
remember this formula for the update and
you can think of these updates which are
coming to x i as a Time series right so
you you run this thing layer by layer
and for each layer you have for example
same coefficients and you have
time sampled data this the the
aggregated message from Neighbors and
you can pass this uh gamma to some
recurrent neural net or Gru or lstm and
you can
take into account the previous
information from previous timestamps
right so different ways of calculating x
i different ways of updating
and potentially some other things for
example pooling we didn't consider
pulling here but you can think of a
pulling as a constructing a new graph
for example reduced graph by some
algorithm with some new features or a
global pooling where you have a graph as
input and some again value or tensor or
vector as output but without
graph so you lose all your topology you
just generate some single value or
single Vector which is useful for
example for classification of graphs and
usually you will have this as output of
your network
now we will see some example in pytorch
geometric but first of all I'd say I'd
like to say a few words about some basic
principles behind Python's geometric so
it is based on Library called pytorch
probably you've heard of it you can
Implement different types of neural net
in pytorch and it has some features like
automatic differentiation a good way of
creating new layers Etc and this basis
is taken from Python's geometric and the
library called so sorry this basis was
taken from PI torch and the library
called python geometric was created on
the basis of it and we have the same
notation of back propagation data set
Management training loop everything is
the same
the only difference is how do we
construct our data representing graphs
and how do we construct particular
layers represent responsible for graph
neural Nets but everything else is the
same as for regular neural Nets okay
let's see some example so this python
geometric has some Hello World data sets
some simple data sets which you can try
and train your very simple neural nets
for example there is a data set data set
called enzymes which is a collection of
some molecules right and this is a
classification task so as input we have
different
molecules and you want to classify to
one of six classes for example let's
take the data set is a collection of
these graphs let's see what is like one
item of this list so this is
representation of a single graph what do
we see here so for example Edge index
represents this two by number of edges
Matrix it means that in this particular
graph we have
168 edges
and X is our feature Matrix this means
that we have 37 nodes and each node has
a vector associated with it with three
components so each of 37 nodes has a
feature Vector of size 3 and since it's
a classification task we have only a
single label Y which is one meaning that
well it's just a it's not a value but
it's a dimension like it's just a single
scalar
this is a example of graph you can
construct your own data sets with your
own representations but this is the
commonly used in Python geometric
uh next we have a data order one of the
main features of that it can produce
batches of your graphs because if you
can think of batches it's not so trivial
for example as vectors and images in
images and vectors you just stack them
together by another dimension and that's
your batch how do you deal with graphs
how do you construct batch actually it's
pretty simple you can just put all of
your graphs like together in and you can
think of it as a just one giant graph it
just means that between these two graphs
you have no connections no edges but the
set of nodes is aggregated all together
I mean in the uni UNIF unified set of
nodes edges as well they are preserved
and the only difference is that we need
to track which nodes correspond to which
initial graph for example it will be
used later when we will do pooling
operation but we will need this only for
a specific sub graph
so again let's use this data loader to
create a batch for example for size with
size of four
and let's take just one example so data
is the object containing the whole batch
and it will has let's see it will has
it will have the edge index x y and also
another
field called batch and we also print the
batch here and you will see that this
the the this tensor the last tensor just
represents the labels of the graphs
within that batch so we have batch of
four graphs and that means we have like
first I don't know
first I don't know like 90 edges are
graph number zero then we have graph
number one then graph number two Etc
all the edges and X's are just stacked
together so initially we had two by
something for each graph and we just
stack them together that means that
382 is the number of all the edges in
within these four graphs
uh 93x3 means there are 93 nodes in this
uh four graphs and we have four labels
and that's it and PTR is just a index of
where we have the starting point of
graph number one graph number two Etc
within this array that's pretty simple
okay let's now construct the simple
graph neural net model we we import some
Pi torch Basics like neural net
module and some functional module and
for pytor's geometric we import a layer
con called gcn conf which is basically a
graph convolution and Global mean
pooling for pulling all the nodes inside
our graph
within gcn conf the message passing
protocol is already implemented somehow
According to some paper so gcn conf you
can think of it as a layer which takes
graph as input and produces another
graph with new features
let's start creating our model pretty
usual thing we create a
Constructor in Constructor we create
this convolution operators with this
layer gcn conf
again this gcn conf takes one graph with
some feature vectors and produce another
graph with other feature vectors and we
need to specify the dimensions of these
feature vectors
input dim is will be taken from our data
set and output dim the size of the
output feature records let's say 64. and
we create three more layers
and in the end after three convolutional
layers we will have the same graph but
each feature Vector will have Dimension
40 uh sorry 64.
and also after that
we will do some linear transformation
after we aggregate all the nodes we will
just do some like final layers and final
linear transformation to produce the
vector with size of number of classes to
do the final classification
and let's create forward so for forward
like our inference operation we will
have x x is usually for data for
features for our nodes
and Edge index Edge index is basically
two by number of Ages edges
Matrix and we also have this batch thing
which will need it as we saw previously
for
distinguishing between the graphs within
a batch
we pass X and H index to our
convolutional layer and it produces the
same graph basically the same X
so the same graph but with different X
sorry the edges will be preserved edges
do not change but features will be
transformed somehow and the convolution
does not include any non-linear
non-linear activation function so that's
we that's why we have this real Loop
function here but we have new features
as output second layer
third layer for this time let's not use
activation function because it's our
last convolutional layer and again we
have the same graph and some features
but new features
now we can apply Global mean pooling
meaning that as input we have graph but
as output we already have just some
features for the whole graph aggregated
from all the nodes and here you can see
that we also pass batch and the question
to you how do you think why we didn't
pass batch to convolutional layers but
we passed batch to Global mean pooling
how do you think
yep that's correct so when we
constructed our batch we should not
worry about the connection between the
graphs inside that batch because there
are just no connections and message
passing will just not work it will not
mix information between the graphs but
then when we pass it to Global mean
pooling if we do not pass batch it will
just aggregate just one value from all
the nodes but we want what's a single
aggregation per each graph within our
batch and that's why we need to pass
batch here and we apply some linear
layer and output this thing
and this is how we construct our model
just created input gene3 because the
feature dimension of our graph is three
and number of classes six
next I will really briefly tell you
about the training
procedure because it's a exactly the
same as for any other type of neural net
you have your Optimizer you have your
loss you have your Loop over epochs over
your batches I don't know the only
difference would be that your model
takes X
age index and batch and everything else
is exactly the same as for other neural
Nets and finally let's consider
a custom way of creating your own layers
for example I showed you how to use the
existing layer but let's say you want to
create your own modification of graph
neural network
for this matter you can create a
subclass of this message passing class
there you can create some layers some
Opera some trainable operations as much
as you can as much as you like and then
we create a forward function which takes
data and edges
and you can start doing some magic here
for example let's add Loops this is a
useful operation commonly used in graph
neural nets for example usually in your
graphs there are no self Loops meaning
there are no connections from Edge one
to oh sorry from Node 1 to node one but
for some operations it is useful to use
this thing so we've just passed our
edges and it will create new edges
containing these self Loops then we can
for each node we can apply some linear
transformation and then we run this
propagate function which basically runs
the message passing for all the nodes of
our graph
so here in this forward function we can
do some manipulation on the Node level
and then when we do did some
transformation on node level we pass it
to propagate and we'll it will start the
message passing protocol
we can create our own messages our own
update functions our own aggregation
functions in this simple case for
example for messages we do nothing
because we already did some linear
transformation we just passed the
message uh
to the x or I node from X J to x i but
if we would like to do some
transformation over xjs for example I
don't know calculate attention mechanism
we can also have not just XJ as input to
this particular message but also x i
right and do some calculations there and
we can calculate the update for example
we can use RNN with an update function
or anything else so and you can have
also a custom aggregation this is how
you create your own graph neural net
layers
and that's pretty much it and finally I
just want to promote you a website
related to our nvidian developer program
when you can have a deep learning
Institute course
and some other interesting sdks and
programs related to deep learning so
just go there and you will see what kind
of interesting information is there
and that that's it for today so yep
please any questions okay everyone it's
time for questions
thank you
thank you uh can we please go back to
the slide with the code
a little bit
yeah here uh so here you have uh in the
forward x equals F value and uh
so classically gnns are defined two
layer gns are defined not uh the way
that they pass aggregate the information
from the same notes neighbors twice but
they aggregate information from two hope
neighbors so is this some sort of
different architecture or well if I
understood it correctly you mean that
the in graph neural Nets you want to
aggregate not just for from Neighbors
but from neighbors neighbors yes in uh
graphene or Nets layers are defined a
little bit differently and when you say
two layer GNN that means that you first
aggregate information from like you have
a node you take it's one of neighbors
and for that neighbors you also take
their neighbors and aggregate
informations from them and then you
collect uh for all the neighbors of your
target node those features from
aggregation or passing through linear
layers and after that you aggregate
again with the feature Vector of your
target node and you obtain a next layer
embedding maybe a representation for
your node so basically if you have one
layer GNN and you pass through the next
Epoch that is when you twice aggregate
from your onehob neighbors
okay so the simplest answer would be
there are no strict rules in gnns right
you can have various different
approaches how can you do this thing
these are just some experiments which
are made in some papers what you're
saying for example for aggregating
Neighbors indeed you can have you can
think of it in two ways first if you
consider this notation then after you
calculate the second layer
it will also aggregate information from
neighboring nodes just because the those
nodes were already containing this
information or in another option you can
think of another layer which will in the
first place in one calculation aggregate
information from several neighbor nodes
not on just one uh neighborhood yes but
here in the code it is written
differently here you first aggregate
from your neighbors and you obtain the
representation for your Target node and
again uh for the next step you again
aggregate from the same nodes so those
nodes don't get the chance to learn from
their neighbors during this time because
you immediately aggregate from after the
first iteration again
yeah but in within the this layer we
have the update function which will
update uh for neighboring nodes They
will receive updates from their
neighbors right
but
there are two layers just after each
other right but within the con one layer
the X the the X which is output is the
whole graph right and for for each node
it will already received okay the X
represents the whole graph each node
after layer 1 already received from all
of its neighbors ah okay I thought
ethics is just a Target node or
something no no so in this notation X
represents the whole graph
okay yep thank you
thanks for presentation uh I have a
question what
are the state-of-the-art models on gns
for unsupervised graph representation
learning
well so first of all regarding state of
the art I must say that this is a very
rapidly changing thing I would say that
the most loved by researchers of now
layers would be graph attention neural
networks graph potential layers
regarding unsupervised learning I'm not
really sure because it depends on how do
you define your unsupervised task but
for example you can think of
you can formulate unsupervised tasks for
graph neural networks similar to any
other unsupervised task you just have a
way to pre-process your graph to extract
some feature information and then you
can train like Auto encoder or do some
clustering so these are like orthogonal
things so you can think of unsupervised
learning similar to what is done for
other types of data and for
state-of-the-art thing you can think of
a particular layers
and as far as I know like graph
attention networks with attention
mechanism are like pretty used pretty
common right now
okay and what about graph after encoders
you you said also that yes yeah you can
I mean you can construct any type of
network using this mechanism right so
why don't you create graph autoencoder
for example if you want to train in an
unsupervised fashion the just features
of the graph
yeah I mean features without labels like
yes
you don't have labels right yeah yeah
just just asking about you know about
state of the art
well it depends on your task because
like unsupervised there are multiple
ways of uh creating that okay thank you
but mostly it's the same as for other
types of neural Nets the only difference
would be just the way how do we process
graphs from layer to layer from input to
Output but the rest is pretty similar to
other types of Netherlands
thank you for your presentation
um I have questions
um
when you explained uh the equations
about uh value updates do you understand
correctly that
we learn weights for each each node and
when we calculate uh wait for one node
and then wait for
um a value for one note and then value
for another node the weights are the
same which I learned right so all the
nodes are updated in parallel like we do
for OneNote but we're not assign it
right away we calculate the thing which
we want to assign to that node and we do
this for all the nodes and then we do
like massive assignment for all the
nodes so they are doing this in parallel
okay do with the same weight and then
when we take a page with several graphs
how do we solve the problem that e H
each graph have different input right so
our each batch can have also different
input and when we want to calculate
something in parallel we should assign
for
some number of course for CPU GPU how do
we distribute it do we make some some
painting well actually we don't need to
because when you say each graph has
different inputs it has it can have
different uh number of nodes different
connections but the feature Vector
length is usually the same for each node
and Bridge graph and you can think of a
a matrix representing the feature Matrix
for one graph as this Matrix for example
feature Dimension number of nodes and
then when you construct a batch you
stack by this Dimension so you have the
same feature Dimension and then you have
number of nodes which are aggregated and
then you use this Matrix and you pass it
to all your linear algebra in and it is
performed in a one calculation you don't
need to do some very much input size is
always the same so we stack several
graphs in such ways that we have the
same input size because first like graph
is like have 10 nodes and then 20 and so
input size is the same yeah that's
correct so okay in this case you can
think of it as a variable batch size so
how to allocate memory I'm not sure
about that so it's some like low level
mechanism but in terms of like algebra
you don't need any padding but in terms
of like memory allocation I'm not so
sure how it's done and weights which we
learn in each graph
how do they apply because we have every
new graph is like our new sample but in
which we learn our ways
and uh with each other's weights are not
for graph weights are for neural Nets so
the the weights are common for
everything which we do so weights for
example you can think of a weight Matrix
is just like
for example this first Matrix will be 3
by 64. it has no nothing to do with
number of nodes or edges or anything so
weights are just for example for second
layer it's 64 by 64. nothing else it's a
uni single Matrix 60 by 64 for
everything it doesn't matter what's the
batch size is doesn't matter what number
of nodes Etc so it's updated and for
next sample is the same
yeah it's the same Matrix correct makes
sense it's different between the layers
it could be the same for between layers
for example in RNN setup but could be
different from each layer ah thank you
presentation I have any question uh
whether uh normalization layers are
usually used for Journeys to stabilize
training to improve performance maybe
there is a specific uh normalization
layer are that differ from that differs
from uh batch neuromisation like in cnns
or layer normalization like in
Transformers
well yeah actually a good question there
is a special type of normalization in
graph neural Nets and for example this
conv layer which I showed here
is actually the same
linear operation which was shown here
but with also some normalization and
normalization works as follows it
depends on how many neighbors
does the Target node have for example if
the the more neighbors the less
normalization coefficient is and it is
computed via the degree Matrix a degree
Matrix represents like for each node you
can have a
number of neighboring nodes
and you do some inversion of this Matrix
and this is your normalization metric so
basically it's used for normalizing the
incoming information for different
situations for one situation you have
not so many neighbors for another
situation have a lot of neighbors and
you want to normalize between these two
situations so that's why one of the
mostly used normalizations is dependent
on the number of neighbors that's a
pretty common normalization other types
of normalization also could be applied
but that's more a specific thing and
depends on the specific implementation
over a paper but the degree Matrix is
usually used for normalizing these
things thank you
thank you
[Applause]